10 quel âge avez-vous 6-4 6-4 et vous
êtes déjà champion de france junior bon
ce que les gens ne savent pas à
l'étranger aussi vous êtes dit si vous
étiez à café s'il est bien commode à
capestang où il n'ya pas de patinoire
il n'y avait pas de patinoire dans
l'hérault êtes vous venu au pathé c'est
assez curieux est avec moi mon père
travaille à paris alors un jour c'était
l'époque de kalma je les dis je suis
allée matinée à la patinoire molitor et
alors tout de suite m'a plu j'ai
continué alors est ce jour là se passer
comme ça s'il y a trois ans et demi et
en trois ans est venu ça vous n'avez
plus le demi jambes et aux bras
j'ai travaillé j'ai travaillé puisque
maintenant les champions de france mais
il ya hélas beaucoup on va faire encore
pour arriver au plus haut niveau
bon vous avez quel âge il était dit
didier voilà le grand patineur de deux
morts je sais mais enfin vous savez ce
sont des résidences que je ne mérite
peut-être pas bon alors votre but
immédiat bateleur d'idées pour moi
maintenant scellé les prochains
championnats de france seniors qui se
dérouleront à paris je pense an prochain
et après et après on verra
petit titre olympique au walhalla à
vivre de gens bien ibra j'avais la
prophétie de gines et il faudra
concrétiser
j'essayerai chez de mon mieux mais enfin
vous savez il ya tant de choses et puis
ça tient à rien alors vous pouvez
continuer à pâtir
voilà ni didier gailhaguet 15 ans mais à
capestang de l'hérault étudiant à paris
quatre ans de patin déjà champion de
france junior les plus grands patineurs
du moment voient déjà en lui le grand
champion de demain
[Musique]